Okay. So what I want to talk
about today is about, uh,
the places where stocks are exchanged
and or bonds or other securities.
And it's another huge industry.
Uh,
I would say it's part of our information
technology or information network
because what we have to do is find a,
a national or international price
for a security. The problem is that,
uh, when, uh, when, uh,
securities are traded
without a central market,
different people will be getting
different prices for the same thing. Uh,
we have what's called
a, maybe the term, uh,
what markets do for us is, uh, important
term is price discovery.
That means that,
uh,
there is a market price
that an asset would have if
everybody in the whole world,
we're free to buy and sell the asset on
the same market and at the same time,
uh, but if you don't have an,
uh, an organized exchange,
uh,
which is open and available to
everybody without a lot of costs,
then you don't have
effective price discovery.
And that means that nobody knows
what the asset is worth. Um,
in a, in the whole market, we
take price discovery for granted,
but we have to realize that there's a
technology that brought us, that, uh,
and it's a technology that I want to
emphasize has been improving over the
years. It's not static. Um, so, uh,
I wanted to start by just
defining some important terms, uh,
regarding exchange of a securities,
uh,
part and calm his broker
and I'll put it over here.
Another one is dealer.
Uh, that's the two kind of people who, uh,
who trade a securities, uh, and, uh,
uh, it's important to keep, uh,
the concept. Uh, and so, uh,
one thing that's used to describe it's,
we start with the letters B o a see that
sounds like it's very British overseas
air corporation. But that's not what I
mean. Now, this is a minimum, an active,
remember broker, uh, it says brokers,
uh,
act on behalf,
for others
as an agent,
uh,
for which they earn a condition.
Okay. So, uh, uh,
broker goes between two people,
uh,
and, uh, the two people
trade with each other.
The broker makes it happen.
And the broker receives a
fee called a commission, uh,
for, uh, making,
bringing these people together so that
they could find each other and make the
deal and make the trade
for dealer.
Uh, we have, uh, different,
uh, it's d h p m.
Okay. Uh, a dealer,
uh,
act
for,
we'll say herself or himself,
uh,
as a principal
for a markup.
That's the fundamental difference.
Uh,
in contrast to a broker,
the dealer actually buys
and sell, sells, uh,
himself or herself. And, uh,
and that means the dealer, uh,
I read, says hesitant inventory
of whatever it is that a, so that
the dealer is, has something to sell.
If you,
if you go to a dealer and biosecurity,
you're buying it from the dealer
out of the dealer's inventory.
If you sell through a dealer,
you sell to the dealer.
Okay?
So there's a fundamental difference.
The mark up is the difference
between the price that the dealer,
uh, uh, buys and sells that.
So you'll see that there's a
fundamental difference. Now,
a securities law says that you can never
function as both a broker and a dealer.
In the same transaction,
you've got to be one or the other.
The same person can do both.
You can be both a broker and a dealer,
but not in the same transaction.
Uh, we also have the term,
uh,
and finance broker,
hyphenated dealer,
that's called BD,
right?
A BD is a firm that hires the employers,
brokers, and dealers. Okay. Uh, and so,
uh,
the fact that they hyphenate,
I'm doesn't mean that any one transaction
involves both broking and dealing.
Um, so, uh, the,
uh, uh, you can see the difference in,
in ordinary life when
you buy and sell a house,
you're a real estate agent is a broker.
But the real estate agent usually
does not buy the house from here.
Or if you're selling your house,
uh,
or if you call up a real estate agent
and say, I want to sell your house, the,
the agent doesn't say, okay, I'll buy it.
So that person is operating as a broker.
However,
if you go to an antique shop, uh, and uh,
and say you want to buy a chest
of drawers or dining room table,
you will be dealing with a dealer.
Right?
And I guess there's fundamental reasons
and why it works out well and one and
why, why did it tends to break
down differently for the different,
why is it that we have dealers for
antiques and brokers for homes? Well,
I think it has something to do with,
uh,
can you tell me why? Why
did we do it that way? Uh,
I was thinking it had something to
do with the information cost of, uh,
since make running a house
is such a big decision. Um,
and you've got to go looking at the
houses anyway, right? Some are antiques.
You wouldn't have an antique
broker. Right. Would you, uh,
the [inaudible] I guess you could,
people could have antiques for sale in
their homes and the antique broker would
take you around on a tour.
And what if that's my blackberry?
So wired up here,
uh,
that was my blackberry.
Sorry about that. Um, so,
uh,
okay. So, uh,
okay.
Um,
so the, uh, anyway, uh, the, uh,
concept of a broker
dealer, uh, is that, uh,
it is something regulated once again by
the security and Exchange Commission.
So that means any broker dealer
must register with the SEC.
So in that sense, we have a sort
of licensing for broker dealers.
Broker dealers in turn
are responsible for their,
uh,
for their employees who are acting
as brokers and dealers and, uh,
the employees.
Um,
we'll have to be appropriately licensed.
And so what broker dealers do is,
um,
according to our securities law,
uh,
they would manage their employees,
exams through Finra. Now,
I mentioned that before.
That's the successor to National
Association of Securities Dealers that,
uh, has exams for brokers and dealers. Uh,
and so what it is that a broker
dealer is a company that, uh,
that hires people and they become a
licensed as brokers are dealers through,
uh,
their own broker dealer using FINRA.
And so that's the organization
method that we have.
The reason why we have it this way is
that there are so many instances of bad
behavior among brokers and
dealers that have to be, uh,
that have to be handled.
And this goes back to a basic theme
of this course that human nature is
imperfect.
And while economics theory
ties to describe people as
honest and following the
rules, there are so many
opportunities for bad behavior,
uh, that, uh, uh, that, uh,
uh,
that have to be corrected.
So I,
I've taken the licensing exams for
Finra because I want myself to do,
uh, to do, uh, we
creating a securities. Uh,
and I think it's actually a
very good program. They have a,
and they have continuing education
that brokers and dealers have to take.
And one thing that they do
and the continuing education,
I was impressed with what
they've come up with.
They have actors and actresses portraying
situations that brokers and dealers
will come up with,
well encounter that are not quite ethical.
All right. So, uh, you
know, you'll have the,
I remember there was a scene where a woman
comes up to the broker dealer and, uh,
there is a document that she has a joint
account with her husband and there's a
document,
uh,
that requires both of their signatures
and the broker dealer hands it to her and
she signs. And then, uh,
and then he says, okay,
can you get your husband to sign
it? And he said, she said, oh,
he already did look right in
front of the broker dealer.
Uh, and then they show the
broker dealer backing down.
This is in a skip that I saw a
and accepting. Okay. She said,
I'm sure it's all right with
him. And so he says, all right,
and then the get goes on and shows how
much trouble he got into for accepting
you. Then there's husband shows up the
next day and they're getting a divorce and
he's furious. And, um,
he tries to cover it up by
pretending he didn't know.
And then she then comes back and admits
that he just told me it was all right
that my husband,
I could sign for my husband.
So there's all kinds of moral issues
that arise and I think that the system
works as well as it does.
Uh,
because we have institutions,
we recognize that there's a tendency
for all kinds of bad behavior.
So my own experience
with Finra was, uh, uh,
increased confidence in our
broker dealers. I think that, uh,
we have a good system that there's
going to be a lot of temptation for bad
behavior. We have a pretty good
system in this country for, uh,
for educating people not to do that.
Uh,
we also actually go after broker
dealers who do things that are seemingly
innocent. So for example, churning,
I mentioned this before. Churning is, uh,
overtrading a customer's
account. So, um, it's,
uh,
it's not obvious to an
uninformed investors that it
isn't a good idea to trade
stocks every other day.
Okay. He beat, uh, uh,
but it's obvious to anyone in the field.
If you're trading stocks that frequently,
there's just no way that you
could make money. He hasn't,
there's nobody who can get a 50%
return on stocks with reliability.
You know, we've know that David Swensen,
we mentioned him before, has got 18%,
but he's the star. Right? And you're not
going to do that. Well realistically.
So if you're a jerk churning,
if you're paying more than 18% in
commissions every year, you, you,
you just don't have a chance.
And so I, you know, I broke her,
could try to hide behind some
kind of facade and say, well,
but I think I can learn that,
but unfortunately we have a good enough
regulatory agencies to stop that. And so,
uh,
right now brokers who check to churn
their portfolios will be caught by market
surveillance and they will be thrown out
of the profession. It's actually, uh,
you can be disbarred, uh, prevented
from trading for life. Um,
so that's the kind of regulations we
have. I think it's a very, you know, the,
the world is more ambiguous and,
uh,
faces more of moral dilemmas
than you would imagine.
You have to get out into the business
world and start seeing how often they come
up.
And it's kind of remarkable that we have
a system that handles these dilemmas as
well as we do. You see a lot
of anger now, like for example,
with the subprime crisis and people
who supposedly or allegedly behave very
badly and it's certainly some
of them did behave badly,
but we have a system
that, uh, I think, uh,
has developed over many years
that that works pretty well. Um,
now these are so brokers and dealers
are people who work with the exchanges.
Uh, but I want to go on to talk
about the exchanges themselves.
Okay. Um, on which these people trade.
And this is unfortunately a difficult
topic to keep up with because,
uh,
the exchanges are changing every year.
And I think a big impetus for change is
the advance of information technology.
And I might say also financial technology.
This is a world in rapid change.
Uh, it's not a fixed at
all, but, uh, wanted to
talk about different kinds of exchanges.
We have traditionally we say
in the U S or four markets
and one of them is
called the first market.
Okay.
Uh, and this is traditional. Uh,
and that is New York Stock Exchange.
I'm going to come back,
it's now called NYC year or next,
but let's just be
traditional for the moment.
New York Stock Exchange is the
old original stock market, uh,
and the dominant one.
And so we call that the first market.
Then there's the second to market.
Uh,
and that is Nasdaq.
Okay. And that's, uh,
that stands for National Association
of Secure Securities Dealers.
Automatic quotation system.
Uh,
that was the first electronic exchange.
it was founded.
Okay.
New York stock exchange
was founded in 1792.
Nasdaq was founded in 1971.
Very different tradition,
uh, between the two. Um,
and um,
oh,
I should say the second market I have
to add that is the NASA Nasdaq national
market is Nasdaq,
uh,
is divided into two parts.
There's the national market
and the third market,
so called third market
is Nasdaq small cap.
Okay.
Small cap is means companies with
capitalization is low capitalization.
Remember is the price per
share times the of shares.
So it's the value of the
whole company. Uh, and, uh,
uh,
the small caps are,
are treated separately on Nasdaq,
and then there was the fourth market.
Uh, and that's, uh, beyond
the exchanges itself.
This is as large institutions
trading amongst themselves.
Okay.
Uh,
it does happen.
There's no law saying you have
to go through and it an exchange.
You can just buy and sell whatever.
And especially if it's a very large
transaction, uh, it can happen that, uh,
as part of some deal, uh,
institutions will trade shares, uh,
and they don't have to go
through the market. But, uh, we,
we really think that these are
the most important, uh, markets.
Uh,
so let me incidentally,
these are not the first stock ish and
the United United States did not invent
the stock exchange. Uh, and I think
maybe I mentioned this before,
but [inaudible] who,
who's a professor at Stanford,
uh,
has researched the ancient Romans stock
exchange and claims to have identified,
I think I said this before, has a claim
to identify where in the Roman forum,
the Roman stock brokers a work and
it was out of a certain temple.
You can find the location when you
visit Rome. Now I think it's in ruins,
but you can find where they traded stocks,
but it was never very big.
Uh, and then some people say Antwerp
had the first modern stock exchange,
I don't know, like many centuries
ago. Uh, Amsterdam was an early,
uh,
London was an early stock exchange so we
came kind of late in the United States
to stock exchanges.
1792 is kind of late in the world history.
Uh,
however,
I think that the u s actually features
somewhat prominently in the history of
stock exchanges because there
was a New York securities law
1811, which, uh,
it became a model for securities law
and which made the stock exchange in New
York especially important.
The 1811 securities law in New York,
uh,
established two important principles.
The first one was that anybody can set
up a corporation and have it traded on
the stock exchange.
Anybody who follows,
who satisfies some criteria
specified by securities regulator,
but the criteria did not involve,
uh,
the state legislature convening
and giving you permission.
It was automatic. Okay. Who
doesn't matter who you were,
they would do anybody. But of course
there were, there were restrictions then,
you know,
the company may have had a certain
capital requirements and they're like,
but it was democratic until then.
It used to be that in many countries,
companies would require an act of
parliament to be founded or the king would
have to sign something. Uh, now it
was very clear that it was democratic.
The other thing that New York
securities a lot of 1811 did is, uh,
make it law.
That limited liability,
uh,
was always and standard.
And that is that limited liability means
that you as a stock market investor can
never be sued for the Miss Doings
of the company you invested in.
This was a very fundamental step in,
uh,
securities law because before 1811,
while there were some limited liability,
the idea was already out there and some
companies put limited liability clauses
in their charters.
It was never clear,
never so clear as in New York.
Uh,
and so you didn't want a trade and buy a
few shares on some exchange because you
had the possibility of getting hit
for that. They could come after you.
Uh, so, uh, with the New
York Security Law of 1811,
uh,
the New York stock exchange began to
really prosper because then it became
something that anybody in
the world could come in and,
and buy a share there and have no worries,
except you can only lose your money that
you've put in and nothing more. So, uh,
that turned out to be a
very important innovation,
which came in the u s and accounts, I
think for the importance of New York, uh,
in finance. Uh, it was copied, you know,
later in the 19th century, Oliver Europe,
this, this, this kind of securities law,
but it took a long time. Okay. So, uh,
the New York stock exchange
was founded in 1792,
uh, outdoors under a buttonwood
tree. I've always wondered what,
what was a buttonwood tree? Uh, the,
I guess somewhat some stock
exchanges occurred in coffee houses.
People used to like coffee
just as they do now.
And that's like a good
place to trade stocks.
You'd be it at Starbucks or something in
London for the equivalent of Starbucks,
and it will be a natural place
to trade stocks. Uh, but, uh,
actually the New York Stock Exchange
was founded under a buttonwood tree.
I looked it up a buttonwood
tree. It's just a sycamore,
uh, or American plane tree.
And we have them, I'm just wondering
why we have them around here.
They're just outside somewhere.
Um,
and I don't know why they call them button
woods and maybe they've made buttons
out of them. Oh, the
wood. Uh, but, uh, so,
uh,
the system has gone on now
for well over 200 years,
but it's changing, uh, because
of, uh, our technology. Uh,
and, uh, so, um,
it's one of the themes of my
book,
new financial orders,
how much technology has advanced our
financial markets and institutions.
So there was some,
uh,
if you look at the number of stocks
traded on the London Stock Exchange,
say around 1800,
it was just a handful.
It was just not very big
or not very important. Uh,
but it was certain kinds of information
technology that really made stock
exchanges, uh, take off. I like
to just mention a few of them.
Uh, one was, uh,
we were living in a very
primitive world in 1800. You know,
people were actually using
feather pens. Uh, that was,
that's what you would
use. And at that time, um,
also paper, it was very expensive
in 1800, if you bought a newspaper,
if you look at newspapers from 1800,
there'd be a single sheet typically
that folded in half of paper.
And why was that? Well, it's
because paper was so expensive, uh,
because in 1800 paper had to
be made out of scraps of cloth.
They didn't have wood pulp paper, and
they didn't have had to be made by hand.
You'd have people, you know, uh,
washing the fabric and then laying it on
a screen all by hand and then enrolling
at then. So, uh, it was too
expensive. So, uh, we got, uh,
in the 19th century,
we got cheap paper.
Uh, uh, and then, uh,
we got, uh, uh,
I mentioned think that's important for us.
We got carbon paper.
This came in the 19th century,
a lot.
There were some maybe primitive
version allowed you to make copies.
The typewriter that came in, uh, in, uh,
19 late 19th century. Uh, so you could,
you could make records much
more accurately with a,
and make copies and that's important to
net copies so that they're backed up.
Uh,
we had printed forms, although
those actually go back, uh, to the,
in Holland. I think we traced them
back to the, maybe the 17 hundreds,
but the idea is having a document with
spaces to fill in numbers and then you
put it in the typewriter.
You've got printed up multiple copies of
this with carbon paper between them and
you type. It's very accurate. Uh, it
makes it possible to do business. Um,
we invented filing cabinets
in the eighties and nineties
comparatively recently, isn't it?
You kind of amazing filing cabinet.
We have the drawers that come out and
you put file folders and it wasn't until
the 1890s,
uh,
that came in before that you would take
documents and tie them up with ribbons
and put them on bookshelves. Well, it
may have been other systems as well,
but we didn't have the
modern filing cabinet.
But the really important thing
was electronic technology. Uh,
and we had the telegraph,
which came in, uh, by Samuel Morris. And,
um, when was the 1840s,
I think I might have it.
Uh,
Samuel Morris graduated from
Yale University in 18, 10.
Uh, and he patented the Telegraph, uh,
in 1837 so it was 1837.
Uh,
so as I mentioned, there's also a college
here or any of you from Morse College?
Yes. Go only one. Nobody else from
Morris. Oh, there's a good number. Yeah.
Uh, so, uh, he did something
very important. Uh,
incidentally,
he lived,
his house is a 58 Trumbull,
which is a three blocks from here.
And if you want to,
you can walk over there
and see Moore's house.
He used to have a inventions,
uh, parked out on his front lawn,
but they're not there anymore.
They've taken the, taking them in.
But this is a very important invention
because electronic communication, uh,
instantly or at the speed
of light essentially, uh,
is what now underpins our exchange.
Um,
and, uh, but the next thing
that happened, and that's, uh,
a little bit later in the
technology was the ticker machine.
Uh, and it's not entirely
clear who invented it, but, uh,
because there's various versions.
But apparently it was
invented by Thomas Edison.
Uh, and the, uh, this was, um,
he was, uh, he, this was his first event.
You've heard of many inventions and
Thomas Edison quite remarkable that his
first invention was in
the area of finance.
And so that was in 1867.
And how old do you think he was
when he invented the ticker machine?
He was 23.
So that's just so those of you
who are thinking of your careers,
some people get started at are good
young age, uh, and doing this was a,
this was a, the Annie, you can't
even know what a ticker machine is.
Uh, do you know what I'm talking
about? I take her machine,
if some of you do anyway,
uh, what it was was, uh,
like a computer printer. I mean, he
was just like way ahead of his time.
We have these printers. You have one
in your room or somewhere that, uh,
when the electronic signals come to
it and it prints out a on the paper,
uh, well he didn't, he
invented one in 1867.
Uh, what, uh,
did you remember the telegraph from
machine that Morrison invented?
Uh,
was it required humans on both hands?
One person would be tapping on the Morse
code on one end and there'll be another
person listening on the other end
who would transcribe it by hand.
So Edison thought, well, there's no reason
why it shouldn't be done mechanically,
uh, at the receiving
end. So he invented a,
a sort of automatic typewriter that
printed out and the initial application of
it was to a stocks because that was,
that's the kind of information people
needed continually on a big basis.
So he invented this printer. Uh, and uh,
it's a little different from modern,
we have a standard paper size now,
which is eight and a half by 11. Right.
But he didn't want to use all that much.
Remember, paper was more expensive and
he didn't need to get a lot he wanted.
So he changed the shape of it.
So the paper instead of being
that wide was like that wide, uh,
because all he had to do port
was put symbols for stocks, uh,
abbreviations for their names and
then the price at which it traded.
Uh, and he wanted to get a lot
of these in rapid succession out,
so he didn't need a wide width.
Right. It's very all very logical.
So it was basically a computer
printer with a narrow, with,
I forgot to bring it today.
I should have,
I was telling someone at the New York
Stock Exchange that I was telling my
students about the ticker
machine and students didn't,
my students didn't seem to know anything
about it. So then he sent me as a gift,
a ticker tape. Uh, it was
just the roll of paper tape.
So they were using a ticker tapes at
the New York Stock Exchange until 1964 I
think it was a, and he said, well,
we still have some in the attic
here and he gave me a role.
They don't try to bring
it. So, uh, um, this,
this is just maybe a curious history
about, uh, communications. But, uh,
do you know what a ticker tape parade is?
Some of you are,
uh, the, um,
uh,
these ticker machines used to be
printing out stock prices. Oh,
constantly. And so this tape was
just constantly running and sorry,
it would pile up in these
huge wads of, uh, you know,
of paper tape. And so, uh,
they had always dispose
of it at the drawbridge is
cause all this paper tape had
to be thrown away and it
was a disposal problem.
Whenever there was a parade down
Wall Street, people would, uh,
they would use this ticker tape like
confetti and they would tear it up and do
the shorter legs and they
would toss it out the windows.
And so you'd see all this paper
tape coming down. So we still are,
this is all obsolete now, but
it's in a sense, it's, it's,
it is electronic communication
technology, uh, that, um,
uh, and I guess we're still
wasting a lot of paper, right?
And we just change the width. So we
don't call it tape anymore. Uh, uh,
we call it printer paper or
something like that. So it's not the,
not exactly the same. Uh, uh, so,
uh,
okay.
So, uh, the, uh,
is the idea that we should
have one market, uh,
w w when we have a ticker tape machines,
uh,
we still use the word ticker symbol
for the short abbreviation of a stock.
Okay. So, um, every stock
has a, a abbreviated name.
We don't need abbreviations
anymore because our printers
are much more effective,
but we still have them. Uh,
and so that's the official,
the ticker symbol is the
official name for a stock, uh,
or other security that's
traded on an exchange.
Uh, so, uh, when you have
electronic communication,
it should create a national
market, uh, uh, that,
uh, uh, is where everyone
is getting the same price.
However, it doesn't necessarily
work automatically. Uh,
in 1975,
uh,
people made a number of complaints to
our lawmakers in Washington that in fact,
while we have ticker machines and
we have a lot of tea, actually,
they were already gone by 75. But, uh,
there were a lot of electronic
communications, but we're,
some people were not always getting
the same price. Someone would say,
I placed my order and the Philadelphia
Stock Exchange and I got a bad price.
Uh, I realized later I could have traded
at some other estate. Nobody told me,
uh, at at the same time. And
so, um, so congress created, uh,
it was the securities act of 1975
wanting to create a national market
system.
Uh,
and so congress mandated that securities
brokers set up some kind of electronic
system that would allow people to trade
on whichever exchange has the best
price.
So it was a center of a challenge to the
monopoly of the New York Stock Exchange
because you're a broker. If you place
an order with your broker, uh, this,
we would have a new electronic system.
So they broker would look over all the
different exchanges and see which one has
the best price.
And so that's what you want as a customer.
So it was implemented
with something called the,
its a her market trading system,
uh,
uh, which allows a broker to look over
all the changes and find the best price.
And that was set up with
computers in 1970 in the early 70,
[inaudible] 1975, uh,
or shortly after 1975.
And so it's been in place,
uh, ever since. Uh, however,
um, it was because it was
mandated by Congress. Uh,
the computer system was up to date and
modern in the early seventies or late
seventies, but it hasn't kept up. Uh,
and it's become considered a
slow as they sort of dinosaur,
uh, and uh, um,
people want to avoid trading
in it. So, uh, in, um,
2006 all the major exchanges,
uh,
propose that we replaced the,
its with something called and s linkage,
which is just a more modern version
of the computer technology. But,
uh,
I don't,
I haven't heard anything about
it being implemented. Now again,
since I don't trade,
I maybe if some of you knows what's
happened with this NMS linkage system when
we put this NNS linkage was from host.
But you see what's happening when the
government tries to mandate a linking of
exchanges,
that's not the same thing as having a
market impetus for linking of exchanges.
Uh, and so, uh, uh,
what's actually happened is really
ignoring the national market system.
Computer technology has
advanced so rapidly.
It starts to create opportunities for
people to set up their own competing
systems and who cares about the its
which is a dinosaur which nobody likes.
Uh, and so that, that's
something we have to,
that there's different approaches and
there was going to be clever people who
come up with new ideas about
how to trade stocks. So,
um,
this brings us to the so called e c ends.
Uh,
they were called the electronic
communications
networks.
Uh,
and what happened was with the advent
of the Internet in the mid 1990s,
people started setting up websites that,
uh,
they look like stock exchanges, but
maybe they weren't. Uh, the, uh,
um,
I guess the first one was instant that,
uh,
I'm not sure it's the absolute first one,
but instant that was, uh,
now understand that the exchange
has to register with the SEC.
And the SEC has all kinds of requirements.
Uh,
and if you're setting up some website,
you probably can't satisfy all those
requirements. So instant that set up a,
an electronic bulletin board I call it,
which was not an exchange,
but it was a place where people interested
in buying and selling shares could
post their interest. It was like
an electronic bulletin board. Uh,
and uh,
uh,
so it will be especially important for
people who are placing really big orders,
uh, because, uh, they might want to, uh,
not just put it on the floor of
the exchange, but to, uh, uh,
they might want to
say something on the,
on the thing about,
you know,
under what conditions I would
buy this or something like that.
So it became more flexible and became
very popular among institutional traders.
Uh,
then there are a number of other easy
and now the FCC allowed them to be,
to function as ECM, which
is a separate category. Uh,
and they start to look like exchanges.
And I guess the legal history
of this is very complicated. Uh,
they ended up merging with exchanges.
This is in the 1990s
and early two thousands.
I remember one that impressed
me because I heard in the 90s,
the talk from the founder island was a,
uh,
exchange that was created
when you see this, um,
that was created, uh, for small investors.
Uh, and uh, it actually started to
look a lot like an exchange. Uh,
what I found interesting about island,
they,
the person that I heard speak
about it in the 90s, uh,
spoke of this as democratizing
institutions and it was
the web culture taking
over what the stock exchanges had done.
Uh,
and so what island did is it posted it's
limited so-called order book order book
on the web to the whole
world to see, uh, and uh,
uh, it, uh,
it was kind of challenging stock
exchanges which had kept the order books,
uh,
more or less in secrecy.
So let me just step back and let's go
back to what happens on an exchange and
how instant that in Ireland are different.
There was another one,
another big one was called archipelago.
That sounds like Ireland
archipelago
was another website that you used to be
able to get on and you could read these
order books for any stock
and you see some, but let me,
let's step back and
talk about what goes on.
Traditionally at the New York Stock
Exchange, and it still goes on today,
the New York Stock Exchange,
which is the biggest
stock exchanges in the US,
but also in some ways
the most old fashioned,
they still have a floor trading floor.
Most dark exchanges, um, have uh, uh,
abolish their trading floor. I
just gave a talk in Moscow, uh,
at their stock exchange and
I was mentioning something
about trading floors and
someone raised his hand and your
audience that you're talking it,
the Russians stack exchange trading for,
that's where my Tarko,
I didn't even know I was in it.
Uh, I was in the German, uh,
Frankfurt Stock Exchange, uh, and I
was, uh, uh, they said, let's show,
I'll show you our trading floor.
So I walk in and I just see a bunch
of school children. And they had,
there was nobody there
except schoolchildren. And
it turned into a museum.
That's what's happening all over the
world. Everything is going electronic.
But the New York Stock Exchange and the
Toronto Stock Exchange and the American
stock exchange of a few, uh, x
versus the Montreal, I forget now.
Anyway, there's very few that still do
it this way, but we still have a floor.
Okay. And so, um, you have, um,
for each stock you have a specialist who
stands and a post on the floor of the
exchange. So each stock
has a specialist. Okay.
Uh, and then, uh, you have, uh,
trainers who roam around
the floor and go to, uh,
these are, uh, brokers are
dealers who are, um, uh,
who are trying to buy and sell stocks.
Uh,
and they go to the various posts,
uh, and they make their rounds.
They have so many stocks they want to buy
and someone that they want to sell and
they go around, uh, uh, on
the floor of the exchange.
And if they want to buy a
particular company, they go to,
they know where that specialist is
and they go there on the floor of the
exchange.
They can either
buy and sell from the specialist who is
a dealer who maintains an inventory or
they can buy and sell from anybody else.
They meet at the post because
everyone there is licensed.
It's not open to the public.
So what happens is there is a crowd that
develops at each specialist post and
the crowd, uh, consists of, uh,
people who,
uh,
who decided to go to that
specialist post to look, uh,
uh, at what they want, uh,
the passively by herself so that they
can buy and sell with from anyone.
The specialist is sometimes just standing
there watching and it's all happening.
But the specialist and the New York Stock
Exchange maintains that the specialist
fulfills an important function,
which is to create an orderly market.
So the specialist has a
responsibility as well as a,
an opportunity the other people at the
crowd or just doing their own business,
but the specialist is supposed to be
obligated to preserve a good market.
So if for some reason the
price prices dropping rapidly,
uh, and the specialists
thinks something's wrong,
the specialist is supposed to come in
and buy a on his or her own account to do
it. That's an obligation. Uh, and so, uh,
uh, there've been, there have
been problems. For example,
in 1987, when the stock
market dropped precipitously,
there are criticisms of the specialists
for not buying to support the market,
but then specialists said
in their own defense,
what can we do with
the market is crashing.
So it's not clear that specialists
make a huge difference, but,
uh, that's the presumed
advantage. Now, it used to be,
this is an interesting historical
thing that, ah, in the,
before the 1930s, uh, there were,
um, there were two crowds
on the stock exchange.
There was the, um, the buy sell crowd. Uh,
and there was another part of the floor.
Uh, I can't find this in my notes,
uh,
where stocks would be rented.
I had the dates here and I don't remember.
I can't find it in my notes.
Um,
well, uh, shares are,
it's called the lone crowd.
There used to be a special part of the
floor of the New York Stock Exchange
where stocks would be lent
rather than sold, right?
There's two things. You can do
it, there's two kinds of trades,
but you got to a real estate broker.
You can say, I want to buy a house.
Or you can say,
I want to rent a house and the broker
can do both of those for you. Uh,
same thing with stocks. You can say,
I want to buy a stock. Or you can say,
I want to rent a store,
or you can go the other way.
I want to sell a stock and I'd like
to rent out. And I started, well,
why would anyone want to rent a
stock? Uh, or rented, uh, well,
that's called short sales, right?
They would rent to stock and sell it.
And so, uh, uh, it used to be that, uh,
uh, they, of course, if
you're lending out of stock,
you might demand some compensation
for that. So they used to, uh,
argue at,
there'll be a specialist crowd called
the there to be a crowd that would argue
about the rental costs,
which is an interest cost for loaning,
for borrowing a security. And The
Wall Street Journal used to publish,
there were two stocks sections,
there was the price section and
there was the loan section. Uh,
and that however disappeared in the
after the stock market crash of 1929 and
apparently it disappeared because of
a concern that shorting stocks was the
cause of the 1929 crash.
And the story was at j Edgar
Hoover who was head of the FBI,
thought that shorting stocks had
caused the crash and he didn't like it.
And if j Edgar Hoover didn't like
what you were doing back then,
you were afraid and worried.
So the New York Stock Exchange without
ever publishing it just shut the whole
thing down. And to this day we
don't have a loan crowd anymore.
We do still lend out shares,
but it's uh,
it's not done on the floor
of the exchange. Uh, anyway,
the specialist at the floor
of the exchange has a book,
uh, and it used to be a
big thick paper book. Uh,
and what the specialist
would do. Uh, who would, uh,
specialists would a record in the book,
uh,
offers and uh, uh, uh,
bids and the bid and ask prices.
There will be people who would tell them,
um,
the specialist that uh,
I want to sell so many shares at such
a price or buy so many shares at such a
price.
Uh,
and the book would show a list
of orders that were outstanding.
Um, now this back to, um,
I should clarify kinds of orders.
When you call up a broker and say,
I would like to buy or sell shares,
there's different, you can, you can give,
you're giving her a brook Roker and order.
You can give the broker a market order.
If you give a market order to your broker,
you're saying you only have
to give the broker one number,
which is a number of shares.
So I can have a buy order or
a sell order market order.
If it's a buy or all I do is say I
want you to buy for me is let's say a
thousand shares of this company
and whatever price is out there,
it just, you know, get the best price
you can, but they execute it right now.
Okay.
So it only gives me a number of shares.
MMM.
Another kind of order,
however, is a limit order.
Okay.
And with this order,
you have to tell the broker both
the number of shares and the price,
uh, and uh, there is a,
either a buy or a sell.
So, uh, if it's a buy limit
order, you want to say,
I want you to buy the stock at any
price up to the one I mentioned.
So I would give,
I would say like a thousand
shares at $30 this year.
Okay. And that means that
if it's a buy order, uh,
you wait until you don't execute
it immediately, you execute it.
When the price falls below $30,
a person would do this. Who thinks? I
think the stock is a good buy at 30,
but not where it's trading now at 35. So
I just put it in, just tell my broker,
I'm placing,
I want,
I want you to take this limit order and
I don't expect you to fill this order.
Maybe you'll never fill it,
you know,
but I just want it to be
there until I correct it. Uh,
you're disposed to be standing ready
and you're supposed to notice when the
price falls below 30th,
and then you, then you buy,
if it was a sell limit order, you
would say, uh, I want you to sell it.
If the price gets up to
40, uh, and again, if it,
if it's above the current market
price, it won't be executed. Now.
It might never be executed.
Uh,
then there's another kind of
order call the stop loss order.
Uh,
and with a stop loss order,
like a limit order,
you have to both give a quantity and the
price to your broker when you place the
order. But, and it's similar to
it, but it's in a different, uh,
stop a cell. You can have
the same numbers here. Uh,
you can say 1,030, uh, for again,
but it would have a different meaning.
A stop loss order says to sell when
the price hits 30 in this game,
if it were a stop loss order
for a thousand shares at 30,
it would be to sell. Uh, if,
if the price today is
35, all right, not by it,
it's a different motivation that
you would do a stop loss order.
You see the difference. If it's a
limit order, I'm saying, I think I,
the stock is only worth 30.
I want to buy it when it gets
down to 30 with a stop loss order.
If the actual price today is 35 a share,
I'm saying,
I'm worried about the
stock crashing on me.
So I want you to get me out if it's
crashing. And when the broker has to know,
well, when do I get you out? Well, you
have to say when, so that's, this is when,
so you'd be telling if it's a sell order,
you would be selling,
telling your broker, sell the stock
if the price falls below 30. So He's,
he has a fundamental difference, you
know, limit order and the stop loss order.
There's also a buy stop order.
You can tell your broker, uh,
I want you to buy the stock.
If the price rises above 40.
All right. Now, why would someone do that?
Why would you hell have an order to buy
the stock? Only if it gets expensive. Uh,
well, the people who would do that,
or people who've shorted the stock,
and if you've shorted the stock and
the stock price starts going up,
you're in potentially in big trouble.
And so if you worry about that,
then you can take a buy stop order
in place that with your broker.
Uh, so what island did,
uh, I'm going back to.
The brokers used to have these,
all these orders for the market orders
wouldn't end up on their book because it
would just be executed immediately.
It would be gone.
But these limit orders and
stop loss orders would be, uh,
would be on the book of the broker.
And the broker would then know the mar,
the specialist at the exchange
would have this book, uh,
which recorded customers' orders,
uh,
and sort of the specialists
would understand the market
because it would have a
whole bunch of these orders on the books.
Uh,
nice thing about island when it
became part of our web culture,
uh, in the, um, in the 1970s is,
uh, they created their own
book on the web. And, uh,
so, uh, you could get a,
and you can actually, and it
was free open to everyone. Um,
and so, um, so, so you have the, um,
uh,
you'd have my orders and sell orders.
Uh, and this would be something
you could see on the web. Actually.
You can see things like this
on the Webinar too, but, uh,
not through Ireland anymore.
But let's say this is some company.
Let's say it's IBM.
All right. Uh, and, uh,
you would see something like
this, uh, the buy orders,
would you see how I get this?
Right? It will be the first one.
We'd say for $90, a share, 100 shares,
someone's willing to buy a hundred shares.
At 90 a and over here you
would see something like
someone is willing to sell at
$92,
let's say 200 shares.
All right? So, um, there's
no trade here, right?
If somebody is willing to buy at 90 and
someone else was willing to buy at 92,
there was no trade,
then you'll see other orders.
Somebody else is willing
to buy at 89 and a half,
say 200 shares.
And you can see these descending,
I'm just making up numbers,
88 for a thousand shares and so on.
And so we didn't see other people,
someone who's going at 92
and a quarter for 300 shares.
I'm showing all the purchases in round
lots around a lot as a hundred chairs.
Uh,
but you could also have odd lots,
but most of the time people put
round lots on as their trade.
Uh, and so this book would then sit
there. There's no trade here, right?
This is the, uh, this is
the inside spread that is,
that is the,
on the limit order book.
Those are the trades that
are closest to execution,
but it's not a, it's not
an executable trade. Yeah.
Uh, so what would happen
then? Uh, and it was his,
he would watch the book. It says it's not
electronic. It corrects itself quickly.
I don't know what the specialist had
to do with a feather pen. Originally.
They would have to cross these
things out with ink and, uh, uh,
the book was probably hard to maintain,
but now it's all automatic.
So suppose someone comes in
with a buy order for a hundred,
at 90, I mean, a sell
order for a hundred at 90.
So someone's willing to
sell at a lower price.
What happens immediately on this,
this thing you can execute
it in disappeared. Uh,
and uh,
so you see that happening on the book.
And so it's fun to watch,
uh, an electronic book. Uh,
this is what a broker is. See who, uh,
are members of Nasdaq and they
see the electronic trading system,
uh, or, uh,
of course there's many such
books now that are available.
Uh, so, uh,
the dealer at the specialist on
the exchange also has his own,
his or her own bid ask
spread, uh, which is a,
also an offer you're by herself on the
exchange incident island would only allow
one kind of order. Original. Originally
it was only limit orders, uh,
because they didn't,
they had a system where you had to put
it onto their book and so everything had
to appear on the book. Uh, and so it was
just the limit order book originally.
Uh, so the history of this, or let me see,
I guess one thing I wanted to,
uh,
when I was leading up to
is that the EEC hands are,
are history now.
They've been generally merged and acquired
notably the New York Stock Exchange,
which has been a holdout doing
floor trading, uh, bought, uh,
archipelago because archipelago,
it was growing so fast doing this
kind of electronic trading was,
was really catching on.
And New York Stock Exchange began to
worry that it was a starting to get behind
the times.
So New York stack,
these things which were started by kids
and by a young college students in the
late nineties just grew so fast and
they got so big that archipelago,
we're starting to look like it was
going to get bigger than New York Stock
Exchange.
So finally,
New York Stock Exchange merge with them
and they changed the name after 200
years in business.
They changed the name to n y.
S e r Arca X.
Rkx is short for archipelago exchange.
Uh, but that didn't last long. I'm
going to change their name again.
They just merged.
New York Stock Exchange,
merged with the European
stock exchange euro next.
And so now it's called NYC Euronext.
Everything happens so fast. It
seems fast to me. Maybe, uh,
uh, the, uh,
New York stock exchange is in the process
we think of merging with the American
stock exchange. Uh, and
that's happening right now.
Um, but I, uh,
I wanted to just finish
with just a little bit, uh,
of a thoughts about what it means
to be a dealer in this market. Uh,
and,
uh,
what is it that if you are a dealer
operating on one of these exchanges,
you are placing orders effectively
in somebody's book and, and,
uh, uh, uh,
and standing ready to buy or sell a
dealer is someone who is trading every day
and, uh, who has an inventory of stocks,
uh, fraternity. Uh,
and I wanted to just maybe close with a
little thought about what it's like to
be a dealer.
Uh,
I've never been a dealer and I don't
know the emotional thing, but, uh,
the problem with being a
dealer, uh, of any kind,
uh, and maybe it takes
a certain moral stamina,
mental stamina to do this kind of thing,
is that you're trading every day, right?
You're not someone who's
managing the Yale portfolio.
What you're trying to do is make money
every day by buying low and selling high.
Uh,
and you have to be ready to stand,
ready to take orders because
people come to you, right?
Someone will come to you or maybe someone
in a specialist crowd who wants to
place an order, uh, or by herself,
and you have an inventory.
You're like an antiques
dealer. Uh, and uh, uh,
the problem, one problem is that, uh,
your life's work unfortunately as a
dealer is summarized by your portfolio and
your inventory. Uh, that's why I didn't
become a dealer. Actually. I don't,
uh,
I guess you have to have the right
her stomach of steel or something.
But the thing that I wanted to invest on
you is that no matter how well you do,
uh,
your cumulative score is there in your
portfolio and it's a competitive business
and so you run the risk of being
ruined at anytime in your life.
Uh,
and so this just,
I wanted to remind you of the what's
called the gambler's ruin problem because
being a dealer is a little bit like
being someone who goes to the gambling
casino every day. If you enjoy
your visit to the gambling casino,
maybe you want to be a dealer. A,
actually, I don't really enjoy it,
so I just not the right person to do this.
Uh,
but I really wouldn't like about it is
that you always stand the chance of being
ruined. That is losing everything.
So I just wanted to review it.
This is a little bit of mathematics that
is in a market microstructure theory.
Um,
okay. Um, so, uh,
suppose you're a dealer and uh,
you have a way of either winning or
losing money on each transaction,
okay? Uh, and suppose the probability
of winning
on a transaction is equal to p.
Uh,
okay.
Um,
that's the probability of
winning on one of your trades.
And to simplify this thing,
let's say that you either win or lose.
If you win, you get $1. Uh, if you,
if you lose,
you lose $1.
So you win $1 with probability P
and you lose $1 with probability,
one minus P.
Okay?
Uh, so I want to know what, what is
your life life career going to look for?
Like if you're just doing this
every day for the next 30 years.
Okay. Um, well the first
question is, uh, what, what does,
what does the probability of
your being ruined and let,
let's start with the case.
P equals a half.
And let's not say 30 years
is close enough to infinity,
but let's just say you're going
to do this forever cause I don't,
I don't want to have to figure
out the effect of that last day.
What do you think is the
probability of being?
Remember being ruined means having
your inventory fall to zero.
You start with a s dollars.
That's capital s dollars. All
right? Which is an integer.
When s falls to zero,
you are quote ruined.
You don't have any money left
here out of the game and,
and you will be dismissed from the
exchange. You can't trade anymore.
You don't have anything. All right?
So you have to start with something,
otherwise you can't trade it all.
And so acid, something like $100.
If p is a point,
does any of you know the answer?
What's the probability that
I will eventually be ruined?
This isn't something that you got
in your probability theory. Oh,
you got it right. Yeah, I know who
said that. That's right. It's 100%,
uh, you will with
certainty, uh, be ruined.
Uh, and in fact, the
probability of ruin is, uh,
is one minus p divided by P
two.
The s power,
if he is great with them,
0.5 or greater than equal to 0.5.
Uh, that's because, uh, if
you, if you substitute in 0.5,
this is one. So the probability
of ruin is one, but, uh, if it's,
if the probability is greater than 0.5,
then the probability of ruin will
be something less than one. Uh,
this is actually easy to derive
because think of it this way,
uh,
we call this the probability
of ruin if you have s dollars.
And the reason it has this is because,
um,
if I start with s dollars, uh, there,
there are two possibilities,
either gain one or lose one. So, uh,
this probability of ASCE has to equal
to p times the probability of s plus one
plus one minus p times the
probability of s minus one.
Right?
Uh,
that is the probability.
This is the probability of
ruin. If you have s plus $1,
and this is the probability of
ruin if you have s minus $1.
So the function determining probability
I've asked has to satisfy this equation.
And also we have the restraint.
Probability of ruin if you
have $0 million is one. And so,
uh, this is a difference equation. If
you solve it, you get this. Um, so,
uh,
what it means is that you had better have
a probability of winning substantially
above one or else have an awful
lot of of dollars to start with.
Uh,
uh,
unfortunately it's hard
to get the probability of
winning in any one trade much
up above a half because you're
living in a competitive marketplace.
Uh, and so, uh, if uh,
if p is close to a half,
it's just a little bit above a half,
then you will be standing for your whole
life always with a probability that the
rest of my life is going
to end up in ruin. Uh,
so you may have been very successful and
you now have a a thousand s as equal to
a thousand by the probability keeps going
down, but it never hits zero. Yeah, art.
Okay,
well that's what you have.
That's what people do.
Well, they are taking money off or maybe,
yeah, because they are doing that, uh, uh,
you, you, you live your life
and you, you take money off. Uh,
yeah,
you're right.
I don't have to play it out
to the bitter end like this.
Um,
but I wanted to show,
this is actually this mathematical model
is something that you will find in the
page,
one of chapter one of a micro market
micro structure textbook because you're
right, there's strategies that
can prevent ruin like that. Uh,
but this is the basic, this is just, I'm
presenting this as a very simple model,
um, uh, of what underlies
the restriction on a,
on a broker. A broker has to, has to um,
uh,
main to create a strategy such that this
p is sufficiently probable that this
ruin problem doesn't become a
catastrophic. And the way they do that,
they set the,
the bid ask spread that a dealer has a,
with a consideration of this ruin problem,
which has to be the focal
point of their attention. Uh,
and they have to set the bid ask
spread wide enough so that they feel
comfortable enough with this
probability of ruin. Uh, and,
uh,
if you don't,
of course it's a competitive market and
so you can't get this probability up too
high. Um, and so if you don't like this,
don't become a dealer.
That's the way it is.
So the people who are in this business
are people who can tolerate this prospect
of ruin. Uh, um, but yeah, in
other hand, ruin isn't death.
And that's nothing you were saying,
I can make a living doing
this for awhile and, uh,
I am taking money out and
that's part of the strategy. Uh,
so maybe I'm just being too
much of an academic here. Uh,
I live in great comfort in academia
and these beautiful surroundings.
This university has been
around for 300 years, you know,
I have no worries.
Uh,
and so you might want to consider an
academic career instead of you career and
finance. All right. Uh,
so I hope to see you again then on Friday.
I think we'll have a good
time with Schwartzman.